what is in the most recent issue of
Reason magazine only one way to find out
let's hop to the editor in chief Matt
Welch so every vote doesn't count that's
so sad well it doesn't captain manga
Ward are managing editor wrote a feature
just laying out all of the reasons not
to vote I as someone who is a voter
myself and I no matter I like voting
well one things that she says about that
is that people vote mostly not to
actually affect outcomes but to make
themselves feel happy feel good about
themselves I'm good citizen I
participated and should be treated as
such more than it should be seen as a
way to actually influence elections then
you wrote about four more years of war
basically on going to the Republican
National Convention and hearing two
different Republicans out of see
thousands of Republicans making any
noise whatsoever about limiting even
military spending let alone Americans of
activities abroad those were Rand Paul
he had a good little of four paragraphs
in his speech and Clint Eastwood when he
said why don't we just take our troops
home from Afghanistan but people are so
freaked out they didn't write a chair
thing that the chair that they were like
clapping they didn't understand but the
rest of the Republican convention was
essentially a george w bush
rehabilitation athan when it came to
approach towards foreign policy maybe i
can exceptionalism by the way brock
obama also is a big champion of American
exceptionalism and one of the responses
that uh president obama has said is like
look america is the indispensable nation
we will not retreat from you know these
attacks yeah this is the default
american foreign policy there's
different flavors depending on who's in
charge now but no matter what we see of
ourselves as the nation that is going to
try to be the world's cop and as long as
that is part of the dynamic we're going
to have a target on our back and other
nations in my argument are not going to
come up with their own sense of
responsibility for the world's affairs
and we're not gonna be able to afford
just straight up we've almost doubled
military spending in 10 years and
there's no end of that insight I liked
Peter Suderman calm a lot the headline
on the story is called Obama's failed
narrative
it's an actually pretty empathetic kind
of literary criticism literary political
criticism by Peter Suderman who was a
big fan of Obama's first book of
drinking my father and it talks about
how Obama that has a long history and
central part of his character is to
rewrite hit the history of his own
family of his own story in such a way
explicitly and he admits as such and
such a way to make it seem better to
build a better future which is a super
interesting literary trick it is not so
super interesting when it comes to
governing he says if you what is the
biggest thing you've done wrong in your
first term is like well I didn't tell my
story yeah to the American people and I
was like no actually dude it's your
policies that didn't work but the way
that he is set up is he's unable to
process that come to that butch all
right Matt Welch thank you very much
thank you come pick up reason right now
or be a communist